[Music]
okay fellas we see you hollywood's
finest gentleman cleaned up real nice on
the red carpet but
leave it to the nice glamorous women hey
ladies to give us the ultimate oscar
shivers
[Music]
and i loved the different colors the
combination
it felt it just felt like me because
also there's something about it that
feels very
old hollywood
my better half bought me this purse from
sofia webster and i love it so much
i'm very happy to be wearing something
that a lot of people put work into i
just want to be able to show it off for
them
this necklace do we know how many
carrots it is i don't know but i know
that like um they're security guards
lily james wasn't the only star in pale
pink but the night's biggest trend red
red and more red this is christian
siriano he made it for me they drew it
out and i went that's the one
[Music]
oh my god it's a little pearls and
diamonds whatever and a little carolina
herrera oh my god it makes me feel like
there's bubbles inside jennifer garner
was glam in an off-the-shoulder gown
while best supporting actress winner
ariana debose rocked a crimson crop top
a cape and pants the star's motto go
bright or go home
sorry i had to show everyone my outfit
hers kiwi colored carolina herrera dress
matched the custom david coma look
beyonce performed in it feels good
during the ceremony bee was in a bold
yellow valentino ensemble with a four
thousand dollar purse while nominee
anjanu ellis's custom versace ball gown
took 1300 hours to complete and honored
her late mother it says right there
jack's baby my mother's name is
jacqueline
and so i'm jack's baby
[Applause]
and then there was kristen stewart
breaking all the fashion rules and
custom chanel shorts after posing for
picks k-stew ditched her heels and later
changed into a dress still chanel for
the vanity fair after party
but she wasn't the only star rocking two
looks in one night zendaya went from a
cropped white collared shirt to a full
tux and shout out to her dune co-star
timothy chalamet who went shirtless
under his sparkly louis vuitton pantsuit
from the women's line
other star transformations kourtney
kardashian zoe kravitz jessica chastain
and tiffany haddish who went from this
i'm wearing custom dolce gabbana i am in
italian from head to toe and help
hopefully later on i'll get some italian
in me and i mean spaghetti i mean
spaghetti
to this
[Music]
this what fame look like
this was success look like
this what money looked like
if that's what money looks like then
we're not quite sure how to categorize
this look kanye's ex julia fox dress
featured a claw grabbing her neck and a
handbag made out of real human hair but
she wasn't the only star that got our
attention what's the secret about the
outfit they cut the hips out and i don't
really have hips
so the secret is that you know you just
got to be making a stallion or
pull it off
[Music]
you